يبدو زين تبني واضح لهذه العمليه نرحب
اللواء في زويري الخبيل العسكري
واستراتيجي ونشير الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
اذ قالت كتائب القسام انها نفذت امس عمليه
مركبه شرق مخيم المغازي وقالت بان كتائب
القسام استهدفت منزلا شرق مخيم المغازي
تحصنت فيه قوه للاحتلال ما ادى لانفجار
الذخائر التي كانت بحوزتها قالت ايضا
فجرنا حقل الغام في قوه صهيونيه اخرى كانت
في نفس المكان ما ادى الى اقاع افرادها
بين قتيل وجريح وقالت ايضا قسام بانها
دمرت دبابه ميركافا كانت تؤمن القوه
المتحصن في المنزل شرق مخيم المغازي
بقذيفه الياسين 105 على ما يبدو بانها
عمليه كانت معقده على كل حال محمود تطلعنا
على تفاصيل هذه العمليه على الخريطه
التفاعليه بالفعل جلال سنحاول رسم هذا
التسلسل للعمليه المركبه التي تحدث عن
تحدثت عنها كتائب المقاومه جغرافيا وما
يمكننا رؤيته على هذه الخريطه لا يمكن
فصله بطبيعه الحال عن طبيعه المناورات
الاسرائيليه التي ستظهر الان باللون
الاصفر وهذا شكل تقريبي لتلك المناورات
اذا ما توجهنا الى الوسط هنا حيث
كانت العمليه المركبه لكتائب القسام
شاهدوا معي هذا اللون الاصفر هو بعمليات
المناورات الاسرائيليه التي كانت تحدث
خلال ال الايام الماضيه محاولات توغل عوده
لا يلا نتحدث عن مناطق سيطره اما انما
نتحدث عن مناورات بالتالي هذا الشريط
الاصفر هنا اذا ما شاهدناه هنا في شرق
المغازي هذه هي تلك المنطقه القوات في تلك
المناورات قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تحاول
الدخول من الشرق الى الغرب من ثم العوده
الى الشرق مره اخرى وتقوم بذلك في عده
مناطق نشاهد هذا اللون الاصفر ايضا في
جنوب المغازي والعوده لكن التقدم باتجاه
الغرب في المناطق ذات
الكثافه العاليه للمباني يتم بشكل تدريجي
هنا العمليات حدثت بحسب المصادر على بحد
بعد حوالي 600 متر يشابه هذا اللون الاصفر
الان ا كتائب المقاومه قالت بانها استهدف
بعمليه مركبه العمليه المركبه كان هناك
رصد استهداف لدبابه ميركافا بحسب ايضا
المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي هنا كان
استهداف دبابه الميركافا اولا التي كانت
تقوم بعمليه حمايه المشاه بعد ذلك حمايه
قوات المشات قوات من الهندسه كانت تتجه
الى المباني تحاول تفخيخها ومن ثم تم
استهدافها بقذائف اما تي بي جي او ار بي
جي هي القذائف
الصاروخيه لكن ايضا الان العواجل تقول بان
هناك استهدافا عبر تفجير حقل الغام في تلك
القوه بالتالي هذا التسلسل العمليه
المركبه يمكننا قراءته ضمن المناورات
العسكريه بهذا اللون الاصفر محاولات
التقدم من الشرق الى الغرب محاوله تامين
هذه
المناطق الغربيه او عفوا الاتجاه باتجاه
الغرب من الم المناطق الشرقيه وهو ما
تحاول قوات الاحتلال عاده نسمع نسمح نسمع
دوما بالاحزمه الناريه لكن ايضا قوات
المشاع عندما تتقدم
تحاول تنظيف المنطقه من المتفجرات التاكد
من عدم وجود مقاتلين لكن العمليه يبدو
انها قد تكون تمت بهذه الطريقه يضاف الى
ذلك بان ضمن هذه مناورات في المنطقه
الشماليه سنشاهد
هنا المنطقه الشماليه
اذا ما عدنا الى اللون الاصفر هذا اللون
تغير قليلا خلال الساعات الماضيه هنا في
بيت حانون يبدو تراجع للقوات الاسرائيليه
ايضا في شرق مخيم جباليا هنا تراجع للقوات
الاسرائيليه ايضا عمليات انزال لطائرات
مسيره كلها ايضا حدثت في في الشمال هذه ال
هذا تسلسل الاحداث جلال سنتابع معكما ومع
اللواء فايز الدويري والتي باتت تبت بانها
عمليه معقده وليس ما كشفه فقط الجيش
الاسرائيلي اللواء الدويري اذا القسام
يؤكد بانه نفذ هذه العمليه وقال بانها
مركبه شرق مخيم المغازي استهداف مبنى
بداخله الجنود الاسرائيليون تحدث عن تفجير
حق الغام في قوه صهيونيه كانت في نفس
المكان ما ادى الى ايقاع افرادها بين قتيل
وجريح وتدمير ايضا الدبابه دبابه
الميركافا التي كانت تؤمن القوه المتحصن
في المنزل شرق مخيم المغازي بقذيفه
الياسين 105 كما تصفها انت دائما هذه
عمليه ثلاثيه الابعاد كما شرح لنا قبل
قليل محمود بالخريطه يا سيد يعني اي حتى
قبل ان ندخل الى الاستديو بدات ال الاخبار
العاجله من جانب القسام فاضت نوع من
الوضوح التكامليه والوضوح كنا نتحدث منذ
الصباح منذ اول
حديث لي عنها انا تحدثت عن تي بي جي ولكن
جاءت المعلومات بانها ار بي جي ار بي جي
ار جي عددنا الان الى التي بي جي في فرق
كبير بين التي بي جي والار بي جي نعم نعم
في البدايه كنا تحدثنا وتحدثنا تحت الهواء
بان قد تكون هذه القذيفه و يعني هناك
مراقبه دقيقه مراقبه لصيقه بحيث انه
استطاع ان يوجهها الى اقرب حشوه متفجرات
موجوده ان فجره انفجر المبنى كامل والمب
المبنى هذا مرتبط مع المبنى الاخر من خلال
الداره الكهربائيه او الكورتكس التفجير لا
الان نتحدث عن تيبي جي تيبي جي مختلف حشوه
ترادف شضايا اكبر اكبر اللهب العصف
وبالتالي الان بما انها تي بي جي اذا
التاثيرات الناتجه عن انفجار التي بي جي
ادى الى انفجار احد الحشوات الموضعه
وبالتالي حدث الانفجار والانفجار انتقل
بالتزامن والتوازي الى المبنى الثاني لكن
الشيء الاضافي اولا كنا نعلم بناء على
الاخبار اللي كانت تصدر انه تم استهداف
الدبابه بتدوم او الياسين لا فرق فرق في
الاسماء هذه فقط نشير بانها فيديو محاكاه
لما قد يكون الان تم استهداف
الدبابه بفاصل زمني اتوقع انه يكون لا
يعني قصير جدا استهدفت الدبابه حاله
ارتباك وفوضى استهدف المبنى زادت حاله ال
يعني الدبابه اولا هكذا اقرا الدبابه اولا
هكذا اقرا بفاصل زمني الان اكثر من عنصر
كان ينفذ العمليه لا يمكن لعنصر واحد ان
ينفذ عمليه ثلاثيه الابعاد نعم الان هناك
من كان يحمل القاذف المخصص للدبابه سواء
كان تاندم او الياسين ياسين 105 وبجانبه
بمكان سواء نفس المكان في مكان اخر يوجد
وسيله اتصال يوجد اتفاق على اداره العمليه
تم تم مهاجمه الدبابه مهاجمه الدبابه تعني
حاله ارتباك وفوضى وبالتالي تشد الانظار
باتجاه الدبابه ص حركه غير طبيعيه
بنتيجه هذا الحدث قام العنصر الثاني
باطلاق تاندم على المبنى حصل الانفجار
المتزامن لانه متاكد ان الانفجار اذا كانت
مبنيين انا اتحدث بناء على المعلومه التي
وصلت وبالتالي اذا كان مبنيين هناك اليه
هندسيه من اجل ربط الحشوات وضمان التفجير
باكثر من طريقه انفجر المبنى الان اصبح
هناك ارباك عام هناك قتلى هناك جرحى هناك
الجانب الكيان لم يتحدث الا عن القتلى
الان ستاتي قوات تعزيزيه من اجل معالجه
هذا الموقف غير العادي وهنا كانت المصده
الثالثه حقل الالغام سواء كان يعني كلمه
الالغام دعني اقول هي كلمه مجازيه الان قد
يطلق اللغم على اللغم الحقيقي الذي ينفجر
بطريقه معينه وقد ينسب الى منطقه تقتيل
الى حشوات اخرى سواء شواط سواء غيرها
وبالتالي تم تنفيذ الجزء الثالث من
العمليه هذا يقودني الى شيء وهو الاعلان
عن 21 قتيل اي اين اين الجرحى في ثلاث
عمليات الملخص الحرب العالميه الثانيه في
المعارك وليس في هذه الحاله ثلاثه الى
واحد عدد الجرحى ثلاث اضعاف
القتله هذه في المعارك التقليديه في هذه
الحاله قد المرجح ان يكون اعلى وعدم
الترجيح او اقل احتمالا ان يكون مكافئ اذا
طيب اذا بدنا نتصور لواء الدويري دبابه
ميركافا و مجموعه تؤمن مبنى يقوم فريق
الهندسه بتفخيخ تقريبا كم عدد الجنود اذا
انا كبعد تحليلي الان الذين قتلوا ليس
جميعهم من
الهندسه ممكن يكونوا من الفرقه التي تؤمن
مجموعه الحمايه من الذين كانوا في الدبابه
قتل ثلاثه ف الان هذا المبنى في ظل ظروف
ميدانيه صعبه في ظل مفاجات كثيره نجحت في
استدراج واستهداف قد تكون مجموعه الحمايه
لا تقل عن فصيل مشاه فصيل يعني كم العدد
فصيل المشا الاستاندرد العالمي 33 33 33
مجموعه الهندسه التي اذا كان مبنيين لن
تقل عن ع افراد في كل مبنى في الحد الادنى
صرنا 53 في الحد الادنى لانه الان انا
اطرح علم عسري
الان عندما نقول تدمير مبنيين هذا يحتاج
الى اجراءات والاجراءات تحتاج الى ايدي
عامله مان باور مشان تنفذ هناك من هو يوضع
الحشوات
هناك من هو يقوم بعمليه توصيل من يقوم
بعمليه التاكد من ان كل لانه اجراءات
معقده و ستكون عشرات الاسلاك الممدوده من
الى من من الحشوه الاولى الى الثانيه لانه
بيعتمد هه على اذا كان كهربائي بنظريه
التوال ام بالتوازي وكل طريقه لها
اجراءاتها وهناك الان مجموعه الحمايه
الخارجيه كما قلت لك بالحد الادنى المبنى
الواحد كان في ع افراد هندسه بالحد الادنى
ان لم يكن اكثر قد تكون فصيل هندسه كامل
هو مكلف بالعمليه وفصيل
الهندسه عددا اكثر من فصيل المشاء قد يصل
الى 39 40 وهناك مجموعه الحمايه والدبابه
وهناك المجموعات التي اتت للانقاذ
في هذه والتي اعتقد ان التسلسل الزمني كان
الدبابه المبنى حقل الالغام اذا نحن امام
مراحل مراحل واعداد مرتبطه في كل مرحله
ويبدو بحسب البيان الاسرائيلي بان العمليه
تمت في الساعه الرابعه عصرا بالتوقيت
المحلي بينما عمليه سحب المصابين والجثث
انتهت فجر فجر اليوم هذا يعني بان عمليه
الاجلاء لم تكن سهله سدي
الان اولا هناك اصابات حدثت في حقل
الالغاء دعنا نبدا بالجزء اسهل ا حدثت
اصابات في حقل الالغام بين قتيل وجريح
وهناك عمليات اخلاء حدثت اصابات وقتلى في
الدبابه وهناك عمليه انقاذ واخلاء وهذه
كلا العمليتين اخلاءها قد لا اقول سهلا
ولكن اقول يحتاج الى زمن اقل لماذا لانه
الجثث والاصابات موجوده على سطح الارض
والوصول لها سهل لكن المبنى هو الاص قبل
المبنى القوات القادمه للانقاذ داخل حقل
الالغام ستعلم يقينا وستفترق ان هناك
حشوات لم تنفجر وقد تفجر لانه الكمين
الثلاثي في في غزه اخذ ثلاثه ابعاد وثلاثه
مستويات فاذا هناك اجراءات احترازيه تحتاج
الى بعض الوقت للوصول والبدء بعمليه
الانقاذ والاخلاء سواء من الحقل او من
الدبابه ناتي الى المبنى الان ما هو
المبنى هل هو طابق هل هو طابقين هل هو
ثلاثه طوابق لا معلومات لدي لكن في اي كان
الوضع كل ما تعددت الطبقات كلما ازدادت
الصعوبه الان سيبدا بعمليه
الاخلاء القاعده الاساسيه ان تعتبر كل من
تحت الانقاذ حي وليس ميت وبالتالي لاحظ
حتى في عمليات الكوارث والزلازل متى يتم
استخدام الاليات الثقيله بعد ان ان تستنفذ
كافه الوسائل التي يمكن ان توصلك بطريقه
ناعمه سلسه للانقاذ اذا هم من منظور
المحافظه على اعتبار ان كل من سقط قد يكون
حيا فهذا سياخذ وقت وبلا اخذ تقريبا بمعدل
لا يقل عن 14 ساعه عمل من اجل انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه هذا يقودني الى نقطه ان العدد
الذي اعلن ليس دقيقا لا من حيث عدد القتلى
ولا من حيث عدد الج لانه تحدثت انت
تقديريا ممكن ان يكون العدد يصل الى 100
جندي اسرائيلي لو ممكن نعيد المحاكاه لما
حصل في في المغازي لو سمحتم كي يعني نمر
بها بالمراحل اللواء دويري تحدث بالمفهوم
والعلم العسكري المرحله الاولى استهداف
الدبابه المرحله الثانيه استهداف المبنى
من ثم التفجير ح حقل الغام بما وصف بحقل
الالغام نحن بانتظار طبعا الفيديو بان
يعرض الينا طيب تحدثت عن انه تقريبا 100
جندي هذا هو واضح الاليه طبعا الاليه
دائما تتوجه وفي على جنباتها عسكر جنود
ولا ليس بالض عندما تتحرك في منطقه فيها
قتال هذه تعتبر عمياء وبالتالي هناك منطقه
ميته حتى لا يستطيع معطف الريح ان يكتشفها
لانه يكتشف القذائف يكتشف الاشخاص
وبالتالي يجب ان تكون محميه اذا هناك
دبابه قد تكون في والمرجح ان تكون في حاله
الثبات او لا اقول الثبات لا اقول الثبات
الدائم ولا اقول الحركه الدائمه انما هي
متحركه حسب ظروف الموق اذا تم اولا رصد
هذه الدبابه من قبل افراد وتم
تجهيز التفجير الذي سيحصل لاحقا وبدرجه
الاولى تم استهداف الدبابه كما قلت اللواء
الدويري ب بالياس 10س او تندم او تندم حسب
البيان من القسام ياسين 100 105 تم
استهداف المكاف لتكون ضربه ناجعه لل
المركا يجب ان تكون في البرج صحيح الان
الاصابه القاتله هي تكون في المنطقه
الفاصله ما بين البرج وبدن الدبابه
وبالتالي ا هنا نتابع طبعا هذه اعود واكرر
بانها محاكاه بحسب السيناريو الذي اتضح
انتم انطلاقا من المعلومات سواء كان من
الجيش الاسرائيلي او من كتائب القسام هنا
تم استهداف المكاف هذه المرحله الاولى
حاله من البلبله الانظار تتجه نحو المركبه
ومحاوله
اسعافهم بداخ جاات الخطوه الثانيه الخطوه
التاليه وهي قد يكون بفاصل زمني وهي
استهداف بال التي بي جي للمبنى حدثت
الكارثه بالنسبه للجانب الاخر هذا هو ايضا
نعم نلاحظ استهداف للمبنى الذي كان ملغم
اصلا من قبل قوات وهذا الانفجار هو ناتج
عن ليس مفعول التان دوم وانما المتفجرات
عفوا تيبي جي عن المتفجرات التي انفجرت
المفج لاحقا ياتي ايضا التفجير الذي حصل
الان ستاتي قوات قادمه من الخارج للانقاذ
هذا امر طبيعي مسلم به القوات القادمه كان
ال الذي اعد للعمليه كان مبدعا جدا توقع
الطريق التي سيتم سلوكها من قبل قوات
التعزيز ف سمح لهم بالدخول في هذه المنطقه
بحيث اصبحوا ضمن منطقه التاثير للمتفجرات
فعا على تفجير حقل الالغام طيب لواء دويري
طائرات الاستطلاع لا تفارق سماء كل قطاع
غزه ان تتحرك فرقه بهذا الشكل بالمناسبه
كم مقاتل تحتاج لتنفيذ هذه العمليه تقريبا
في
الحد الحد الادنى ثلاثه يستخدموا القواذف
ام يعني انت الان دباب
وعندك التي بي جي و المبنى ومبنيين الان
تم اطلاق
ال مهاجمه الدبابه تم مهاجمه لابد ان يكون
هناك احتياط لا يجب لا بد ان لانه هذا هدف
تسم يجب على اضمن نجاح العمليه لنفرض ان
هذا مقذوف التي بي جي اخفق وبتالي ما هو
ما هو البديل الخطه البديله يجب ان يكون
هناك ما يسمى الريزيرف او الاحتياط وهناك
ك شخص يراقب مسؤول عن تفجير حق الالغام
هناك شخص معني بالاستطلاع وتمرير المعلومه
وهناك قائد الجماعه المسؤول عن اعطاء
اوامر التنفيذ اذا بالحد قد تكون خمسه قد
تكون اكثر لانه حسب الظروف والمواقع التي
تم استخدامها لاجل الاستهداف اها ف لانه
قد يكونوا في اقول قد يكونوا في مبنى واحد
والارجح ان يكونوا في اكثر من اكثر من
زاويه تمت المهاجم طيب لننهي هذه المحاكاه
كنت اسال عن ان طائرات الاستطلاع لا تفارق
سماء غزه اين الاستخبارات من هذه العمليات
الدقيقه في وقت انت يوجد عدد كبير من
الضباط والجنود يقوموا بتفخيخ يا سيدي
بالامس عرض فيديو عن احد الطائرات التي تم
اسقاطها وكانت عرضوا تم عرض المعلومات
الموجوده عليها فهي تعطي صور ثلاثيه
الابعاد على مدار الساعه
الان يبدو لي ان الحس الامني والاستخباري
عند جماعه
القسام متطور جدا
وقديم يعني وثمره جهد تراكمي وتعب سنوات
وبالتالي كانت هناك عناصر استطلاع تراقب
تعطي اشارات اللحظه التي المتركس 600
اللحظه نعم اللحظه التي يخلو الجو فيها من
الطائرات تعطى الاشاره يتحرك بحذر يعني
عمليه التحذير ل العمليه لا استطيع ان
احدد اطار زمني لانه هناك ظروف متغيره
تلقي بظلالها على اليه تنفيذ العمليه قد
يكون احتاج كما ذلك احتاج الى ساعات من
اجل تحضير المبنى هذا قد يكون احتاج الى
وقت لا استطيع ان احدده خبر عاجل نقلا عن
واشنطن بوست عن قاضه عسكريين وامني
اسرائيليين قد نفقد مكاسب غزه بسبب
الافتقار لاستراتيجيه ما بعد الحرب واشنطن
بوست تنقل عن قاده عسكريين وامني
اسرائيليين قد نفقد مكاسب غزه بسبب
الافتقار لاستراتيجيه ما بعد الحرب ماذا
قال رئيس الاركان هاليفي قال قال عدم وج
عدم وضوح الاهداف سيؤدي الى تاكل
الانجازات نفس الجمله حكاها رئيس الاركان
وهذا وتحدثنا به حتى من منظور عسكري دعني
اتحدث
عن حتى لا يقون متعاطف ويضخم وكما يقال
لدى الكثير من الناس اذا انا اتحدث عن
الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه قائد الفرقه
الروسيه ف فشل في بعض المواقف لغياب
الرؤيه امم واذا لم اكن انا كقائد عسكري
لدي معرفه باهداف و وهذه الاهداف لها
بعدها المكاني ولها بعدها الاداري
والتنفيذي دون ذلك انا تكون خطتي عمياء
ماذا اعمل ما هو الهدف الذي يجب ان احققه
اذا تخطيطي مبني على اوهام اكثر منه على
حقائق انا نعم في حتى في اي
عمليه هناك ما ما يقال الاندر ريسك انا
عندما اخطط لا يمكن ان انتظر حتى احصل على
المعلومات 100% اذا انا انتظرت حتى احصل
على المعلومات انا لا املك العقل وبالتالي
ستفشل عمليتي بحكم انتهاء الوقت الافتراض
للتنفيذ لكن انا عندي الان مرحله اذا
رسمنا
مثلث قاعده المثلث هي قاعده البيانات وهذا
المثلث سيكون متساوي الاضلاع وزاويته 60
60 هندسيا اعذروا ندخل في البعد الهندسي
الان الثلث الاول اذا انا توفرت لي ثلث
المعلومات ثلث الاول من المثلث اوصف
بالتهور انا الفتره المثاليه لاتخاذ
القرار المرحله الثانيه المتوسطه ام لكن
في عند الخط الثاني في الثلث الثاني من
اضلاع المثلث يجب ان اكون اتخذت قراري اذا
انتظرت الى ما بعد الخط فانا جبان ط واضح
اعود واذكر بالخبر العاجل واشنطن بوست
تنقل عن قاده عسكريين وامنين اسرائيليين
قد نفقد مكاسب غزه بسبب الافتقار
لاستراتيجيه ما بعد الحرب ما الذي جعل
الجيش
الاسرائيلي يفقد الاستراتيجيه
ما بعد الحرب بالمناسبه اليوم ها ارتس
نقلت عن قيادات عسكريه ايضا بان القياده
العسكريه وصلت الان وادركت بانه لا يمكن
التعامل مع الانفاق وبالتالي القضاء انت
قلتها من من الاسبوع الاول قلت بانها
صندوق صندوق اسود لدي عاجل جديد لو سمحت
اللواء الدويري فقط انا بانتظار ان يظهر
عندي الخبر العاجل واشنطن بوست عن قاده
عسكريين وامنين اسرائيليين على الجيش
الحفاظ على مناطق
سيطرته لا السيطره على ارض جديده اذا نعود
ونكرر الواشنطن بوست نقلا عن قاده عسكريين
وامني على الجيش الحفاظ على مناطق سيطرته
وانا يسيطر على ارض جديده اعتقد محمود
اجاب هذا على هذه النقطه عيد اعطينا
الجواب مره ثانيه ساعيد محمود تحدث باشاره
سريعه ان هناك انسحابات جرت في منطقه بيت
حانون وفي شرق جباليا تحدث في بدايه
المقاربه واشر على
الخارطه نعم اشر قبل قليل يعني بمعنى اخر
هو اصلا لا يعني لا يحتفظ لا يحتفظ
بالمناطق لا اقول المسيطر عليها المتواجد
بها هو هو ينفذ عمليات اغاره عمليات قتال
من حال الحركه يتقدم ويتراجع وبالتالي ها
هو تراجع في منطقه جباليا وفي منطقه بيت
حانون وانا اطلب من محمود يعني اذا سمح ان
يعيد النظر في المساحات المظلله بالاصفر
لانه الواقع اقل من ذلك بكثير طب طب هذا
هذا يكبله في خان يونس لا يعني عندما يقول
له قاضه امنيون وعسكريون ان لا تذهب
وتسيطر على مناطق اخرى يكبل عمله بخان
يونس يفترض ام الا اذا الا اذا كان
التوجيه السياسي يطالب بالمزيد الان وزير
الدفاع متحمس جدا ان يتوسع
ورئيس رئيس الوزراء كذلك لكن لاهداف شخصيه
هذا حتى ليوصف بالفشل وذلك حتى يهرب من
السجن ا ايضا واشنطن بوست تنقل عن قاده
عسكريين وامنين اسرائيليين شبك شبكه انفاق
حماس اكثر اتساعا بكثير من تقديرات الجيش
الاسرائيلي قبل قليل قلنا اريتس نقلا عن
هار اخر تقرير اخر تقرير كان سب توقع تصل
في حدها الاقصى الى 70 م هذا اعلان فشل في
التعامل مع مع الانفاق تماما لا هو فشل في
البعد الاستخباري ن افضى الى فشل في
التعامل لانه يعني اذا لم تكن المعلومات
المتاحه لي تقدم لي ثلثي المعلومات اللازم
لانجاز عمليتي سيكون الفشل نصيبي سنزو
ماذا قال قبل 2500 عام اذا تعرف نفسك اذا
تعرف نفسك ولا تعرف عدوك فليس لك حظ بما
معناه من النجاح اذا تعرف عدو نفسك وعدوك
فالنجاح حليفك اعطيني رقم انت كم قلت بان
الانفاق تمتد اخر رقم حسب وست بوينت 720 ر
واشنطن بوست تنقل عن قاده عسكريين وامنين
اسرائيليين الانفاق تمتد لمسافه تزيد عن
300 ميل في جنوب قطاع غزه فقط 300 ميل ا
اضرب في 1. جنوب 1.6
1.6 في جنوب قطاع غزه فقط هذه فقط جنوب
قطاع غزه عندما عندما يقول قاضى
اسرائيليون عسكريون وامني بانه لا يمكن
التعامل مع الانفاق هذا هذا اعلان فشل على
هدف اساسي وهو تعطيل قدرات حماس صحيح ن
اولا اين هي قوات القسام وبقيه الفصائل لو
كانت تقا تتواجد هي تقاتل فوق الارض لكن
لو كانت تتواجد فوق الارض هل تعلم انه
القي على غزه اكثر من 40,000 طن من
المتفجرات
وعشرات الاف القذائف وبالتالي هل يعقل لو
كان ه المقاتلين على سطح الارض بقيوا على
قيد الحياه لكن هو متواجد في باطن الارض
في الانفاق ويخرج لاداء المهمه ايضا
واشنطن بوست عن قاض عسكريين وامنين
اسرائيليين من غير المرجح ان يتم تفكيك
شبكه انفاق حماس في غزه بشكل كامل من غير
المرجح هذا ما قلناه ان يتم تفكيك شبكه
انفاق حماس في غزه بشكل كامل ما الرسائل
اللواء الدويري من هذه التس من الرسائل
رسائل تنبيهيه من حيث المبدا للقاده
لنتنياهو تحديدا ولوزير الدفاع ولبقي
اعضاء مجلس الحرب يجب ان تعملوا وقفه
وتستمع للنصيحه نصحناك قبل بدء العمليه
البريه لا ترتكبوا الحماقات الامريكيه في
العراق وافغانستان ولكنكم اخذتم بجزئيه من
النصيحه وحولت العمليه من اجتياح الى
النار والمناوره ثم اصابكم الغرور فتحولت
الى الاجتياح الكامل نعود ونؤكد لكم لن
تستطيعوا القضاء احلى حماس لن تستطيعوا
تقليم اظافر القسام وبالتالي خذوا النصيحه
وعودوا الى المرحله الثالثه مبدئيا واوجد
سبيل للتفاوض لاخراج الرهائن مقابل اثمان
يجب ان تكون مؤلمه
ايضا خبر عاجل اخر واشنطن بوست عن قاده
عسكريين وامنين
اسرائيليين الوجود الامني طويل الامد في
غزه كابوس رفضه
كثيرون في المؤسسه الامنيه ايضا تحذيرات
وهو ما يريده نتنياهو والجناح الاكثر
تطرفا
متطرف هل هذا الجناح يعني دعنا ناخذ
موقفين موقف اليسار وموقف اقصى اليمين
موقف اليسار تمثل في مقوله شهيره لاسحاق
رابين يتمنى ان يصحو في الصباح وان البحر
قد ابتلع
غزه
شارون ومعروف من هو شارون ومعروف مدى
عدائيته وتطرف وهو في اقصى
اليمين اليس هو من اصدر امر الخروج من غزه
اليس هو من اجبر المستوطنين ان يخرجوا من
نت سريم وجوش قطيف اجبرهم الزاما لانه وصل
الى قناعه انه لا يستطيع ان يبقى في غزه
الان
يخرج وزير الامن الداخلي بن كفير لم لم
يخذ اصلا لم يكن له سجل مع القوات المسلحه
لم يدخلها سموتريش الذي جاء من اوكرانيا
الذي ولاحظ جاء من اوكرانيا يطالب بخلع
شجره الزيتون التي ترمز عمرها 4500 سنه
وهو هو امبارح وصل مطرود اوكي الان هذه
رسا انت تشير اليهما لانهم يطالبان
بالسيطره امنيا على قطاع هم يسيطروا
بالاحتلال المكاني وليس السيطره الامنيه
هم يطالبوا بالجلاء القصري بالسيطره
المكانيه بناء مستوطنات واعاده الاستيطان
هم يطالبوا بالسيطره المكانيه وليس وليست
حتى سيطره مكانيه محدده باطار زماني هو
يطالب بالترحيل وبالتالي شارون نفسه وصل
الى قناعه في عام 2005 و2006 لا يمكنه
البقاء ولم تكن القسام هي القسام ولم تكن
الجهاد هي الجهاد الحالي لا كانت بدائيات
كان يعني في تلك الفتره كان الحديث عن
صواريخ القسام واحد انا سمعت لها مقولتين
لا تسقط ذبابه وصواريخ عبثيه في الصواريخ
العبثيه اصبحت الان عياش 250 ا طيب انت
كعسكري عندما تسمع تصريحات وبالمناسبه هذه
تصريحات لواشنطن بوست لما لها من مصداقيه
و وسيط طيب ا اذا صح التعبير كعسكري عندما
تسمع هكذا تحذيرات من قاده امنيين
وعسكريين اسرائيليين لهم باع طويل بينما
القياده السياسيه تقول لك عكس ذلك تقول لك
اذهب حارب احتل مناطق جديده سيطر على هذه
المناطق ابقى فيها حاول ان تسيطر على على
اراضي اخرى بماذا تشعر انت كعسكري وقيادي
هو يشعر بالاحباط يشعر بالالم يشعر بانه
غير قادر على انجاز المهمه لكن يبدو لي ان
شخصيه هليفي ليست هي لا يملك الكاريزما
القويه بحيث يفرض رايه لانه في نعم انا
اخضع عسكري اخضع للقياده السياسيه لكن اذا
كانت القياده السياسيه لا تدرك معنى
الخطوره انا يجب ان ا ان يكون لي موقف الم
يقوموا بتفتيشه قبل الدخول الى مكتب
نتنياهو هل هذه شخصيه رئيس اركان شكرا
اللواء فيز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي وشكرا لمحمود الكن ايضا الذي
رافقنا خلال عرض هذه الخرائط دائما